it's been nearly a week since apple
announced ipad os 16 at wwdc which adds
a lot of much requested features to the
ipads and now after we've used it tried
it out seen its limitations does ipad os
16 fix the biggest issues with ipads and
specifically the ipad pros well let's
talk about that now ipads have been
crazy powerful for many years now but
the biggest limitation was the software
and that hit much harder when apple
added the m1 chip into the ipad pros the
hardware is mind blowing but the
software is very lacking almost
insultingly lacking that's why we put
out a review of the ipad pro saying that
apple really needs to step up and
everybody agreed and going as far as not
buying these because you don't really
get that much extra use out of the extra
power well what did apple add this year
what does it fix and what is still very
lacking so let's start out with the
simple things we have the weather app
now i don't know how many people really
care about this i typically use this on
my iphone but this is the best weather
app when you click on something you have
this full detailed view hour by hour you
have a lot of info about other quality
as far as like uv air quality this thing
is incredible and that's thanks to apple
buying out a company a couple years ago
that gives it this much data i don't
think this is a huge deal though for the
ipad one thing that i appreciate with my
terrible handwriting is a new
straightening feature so when you've
written some text it's all over the
place like this you could actually go
hold it down and then hit straighten now
as you see it doesn't fix my terrible
handwriting but it made it look a lot
better the next thing i really
appreciate is the display scaling option
so you can go over select displays
scroll all the way down and go to
display zoom and just hit more space now
since it's going to restart the ipad um
it doesn't really do that it seems like
it just turns the screen off and then
turns it back on so now everything got
smaller now as you can see we actually
can't add any more applications here we
just have more space between these
applications but then if you go into say
safari you'll actually get a little
refresh and all the text is smaller and
of course if you're using
things that you want to see a lot more
of you want to be more efficient have
more real estate this adds it now one of
my biggest complaints was the files app
with ipad os 15 apple made a couple
updates we finally had a transfer bar
that actually told us the speed which
was nice but it was still severely
lacking now we have this list view where
we have dates we have sizes available to
see we have this sub menu when you open
something up that gives you different
options we can actually go in and show
extensions on all these files so you
know what kind of file it is and then
when you rename it you can actually
change the extension as well now
obviously i shouldn't have done that for
a png but just to show you guys we have
a lot more power we also have
customizable toolbars a system wide undo
and a redesigned find and replace but
some of the things we really asked for
were not added to the files app for
example i just tried to plug in my
external hard drive to show you guys
something and i accidentally tugged on
it while it was being accessed and now
when i plug it in it just simply won't
show up and that's because it has a
little corruption from it being
unplugged accidentally this has happened
to me numerous times over the last year
and then i have to get out a mac or a pc
to be able to plug it in and use the
disk utility to run first aid and
quickly fix this issue and bam now we
can plug it in and our four terabyte ssd
shows up this is something that should
be available on the ipad pro when you're
spending this much money now along with
that the other thing that we needed was
the ability to format a hard drive not
all hard drives or ssds are compatible
and when they aren't you can't format
them to make them work like you can on
mac os or in windows or even on
eight-year-old android tablets so if you
want to erase your drive or you want to
reformat it or partition it you're still
going to need a mac and that should be
built into your files app with all the
crazy ai software stuff they've been
working on that's incredible they should
just be able to make this work it's not
a huge deal now with that we also have a
new reference mode under displays if you
have the 12.9 inch ipad like i do you
can go over here select reference mode
then it allows you to do some fine
tuning but it also allows you to plug
into a mac and then you can use this at
a display that will match specific
professional work cases which is nice
now they do actually have a reference
mode on apple's studio display which is
not a mini led display so i wonder why
it's only limited to the 12.9 inch model
and finally for probably the most
requested feature better less limiting
multitasking and external display
support when apple showed off stage
manager on stage i was super happy
until we got more news about the
limitations of it now let's go ahead and
start off show you how to use it this is
technically kind of like a separate app
it's kind of weird to do you open up
this little pull down the control center
you select that and we are in stage
manager now you don't see anything until
you start opening up some applications
and now we have this window here so
right here i have multiple different
tabs i can also go ahead and grab let's
say my apple music even though i don't
have it logged in here and i can switch
behind it so we finally have one app
open behind another one we can actually
go ahead and make this smaller you can
actually copy and paste from it and you
can pair apps together like this and
then let's say we go back to the files
app bam you swap through here you know
what i want files and i want my mail and
now i can actually just use four fingers
and switch through these applications i
can have different pairings and it does
work pretty well you can in fact make
one of these windows smaller so you have
two of them side by side and i can even
add another one here there you go we
have three applications opened side by
side and then let me go ahead and swipe
through go to my files app overall i am
very happy with this new edition and it
does work well and then if you're not a
fan of it just turn it off and you could
use your regular side-by-side
applications
the biggest issue is the fact that this
is m1 exclusive and it doesn't make
sense why there's a lot of proof that it
shouldn't be i'll explain in just a sec
now one thing that this does also add
finally is external display support
properly in the past with ipad os 15 you
can use mirror display but then you have
these giant black bars on the side
just like that you guys actually just
saw it there for a split second alright
guys so it looks like it is just bugged
out and no matter what i do it is stuck
with the old frustrating version of
having an external display support i
tried three displays restarted there's
no beta update so it's just stuck right
now but as apple showed off on stage it
does work when it's not buggy and it
works great you have a full external
display without those bars you can have
different applications there that you
can open up and run other apps on your
ipad at the same time this is what we've
wanted for years now so since stage
manager works so well why are so many
people upset well the first one there's
no pro apps the apple has been rumored
working on certain stuff we wish we can
get some better applications to make use
of the hardware that didn't happen but
the biggest one is the fact that stage
manager is limited to only m1 ipads and
it just doesn't make sense why that
would happen
now digitimes actually reached out to
apple and they asked why is this the
case and apple said that they are only
allowing it for m1s because it can use
memory swap and access more ram to run
these applications now on first stop
that kind of makes sense all right well
you have multiple apps open you can
switch through them it needs more ram
but if we dig a little bit deeper you
will see that the ipad air 4 with the
a14
actually supports this memory swap
function if you have a 256 gigabyte
version and with that if you have the
base m1 ipad with 64 gig that one does
not yet it does support the stage
manager and external display functions
now some people will say well the m1 has
eight gigs of ram already so maybe that
is why
but older ipads can actually run three
different sets of apps from multitasking
also with picture and picture included
and now with stage manager when we go up
here and we enable this little sidebar
we have four sets that are open so maybe
for the older ipads if it's a ram issue
the ipad pros the previous ones have six
gigs of ram why not just give us three
options instead of four those ipads can
already run that even worse ipads can
now along with that if we take another
step back i was thinking about it and
the a12z in the 2020 ipads that
processor was actually put into apple's
arm transition kit for apple silicon and
that was running full on mac os with
terminal with pro applications
with that processor from the ipad so if
that can run full-on mac os why can't we
run stage manager on at least the ipad
pros from
and
2018-2012
in reality once i did some more digging
there are different reputable people
that are agreeing with this and also one
that actually said that there is code
that will allow older ipads to run it
that you can flag and enable there's no
reason why memory swapping is needed for
simple resizing of application and
allowing an external display to be
connected without these bars here just
to send data over
that is just crazy tablets android
tablets from five six seven years ago
could do these kind of things without
any issues and everybody knows that ipad
os in ios is a lot more memory efficient
than android is i think we all know the
truth apple needs to sell more ipads
that was actually the only category that
declined by 14
compared to macs and iphones and
everything else that actually gained
sales
in the last quarterly reports so people
aren't buying these m1s because the
software just doesn't take advantage of
it and their older ipads do the job just
fine so how does apple get them to
update well they gave them a feature
that is exclusive to the m1s a feature
that works incredibly well gives you
more pro capabilities and you just have
to upgrade to get that now that is
really unfortunate i think we should be
able to have this on other ipads but
this is apple's choice this is what
they're pushing and people will upgrade
because of this
now of course there's other things that
are kind of missing for example the lock
screen functionality with ios the new
widgets that's very nice why can't we
have this on this large display when
you're in the lock screen i'm not sure
maybe they will end up adding that
but overall if you're an owner of an m1
ipad you're going to be very happy but
everybody else is very frustrated that
they are stuck in the past the same
thing goes to people have iphone sevens
with ios
16. technically it should be supported
even if they dropped the 6s last year
the 6s supported ios 15 and now apple is
dropping two years of devices to get
people to upgrade all the to all the
nice software improvements with ios 16.
so pete apple wants people to upgrade
that is very clear you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below was this a good enough
upgrade to ipad os to make it more pro
and to make it worth it i want to hear
you guys thoughts click that circle
above to subscribe to see more videos
like this one check out one of those
great ones right over there this is mid
max and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]